Here's the third constraint, having to do with the displaying of the document.
In this case it's an invariant, it's an indirect, indirect guarantee.
And it's relating the contents that are visible in the viewport to the data
that's provided by the file manager, as far as it's document is concerned.
And it's saying in, in, in effect that the sequence of lines
that we see are determined by the handle position of the scroll, scrollbar,
that is the top line we see is determined by the handle position of
the scrollbar, and we're going to see subsequent lines that and
the number of them is the, is the height minus 1.
That is the number of additional lines plus the top line, that gives us height,
which is what we would expect.
What this says is that what we will see in the view contents percept is that
subsequence of lines that the document, from the document starting with
the line indicated by the scrollbar's handle position and continuing for
height minus one additional lines.